german president frank walter steinmeier
has been re-elected for a second
five-year term
the 66-year-old social democrat and
former foreign minister received more
than two-thirds of the votes cast by an
electoral assembly made up of
politicians civil society figures and
celebrities sean meyer had the support
of all three parties of germany's
governing coalition
nominally the head of state the role of
president is largely ceremonial in
german politics
but in his acceptance speech steinmeier
urged germany and its allies to do
everything to prevent war in europe
the lack of war on our continent ladies
and gentlemen
is something we have become used to
protected by friends
at peace with our neighbors for over 30
years unified again
what a joy this has been for our country
in recent days and weeks we have learned
once again what we should have known we
cannot take peace for granted
peace must be worked for
in a dialogue but where necessary with
clear words with deterrence
joining forces together ladies and
gentlemen and that's what we need now
and for more on this i'm joined in the
studio by dw chief political
correspondent melinda crane and nina
hasa who is at the parliament buildings
in downtown berlin nina scheinmaier was
reelected with a large majority but were
there any surprises
well in terms of election results um
there were a few minor surprises of
course frankfurt steinmeier being
re-elected was not a big surprise after
all he did have the backing of
all the parties that are involved in the
current government coalition so the sbds
the greens and the fdps but also he got
the support from the conservatives from
uh formerly angela merkel's party and
afghanistan's party and that gave him a
solid majority he got more than a
thousand votes now 1
400
more than 1 400 votes were up for grabs
what was interesting though in terms of
results i'm sure that we'll get to the
details of his speech later but just in
terms of results was that the candidate
who had been nominated by the three
voters the only woman in the race she
got more votes than many people had
expected she
would have only got some 36
but she made it more than 50. and also
the candidate who is appointed by the
far-right afd party that had been the
most controversial candidacy max otto
who is a member of the conservatives he
got far fewer votes than
the amount of afd the votes would have
been
okay well those are some interesting
insights i'm going to turn to melissa
melinda crane now um
about the speech i mean that was a
pretty interesting speech um
it sort of ventured into foreign policy
quite a bit was it was the president
breaking the mold somewhat
he was breaking the mold perhaps with
the clarity of his uh messages on
foreign policy but actually his unifying
theme was democracy he started out by
saying if you are fighting to preserve
democracy i'm on your side and the
office of the presidency in germany
actually was created to stabilize the
then young german democracy so this is a
traditional theme for many presidents
but it's been an especially strong theme
for him also in his first term in office
so his messages on the external threats
to democracy essentially were all
addressed to russia and president putin
with steinmeier saying very clearly
russia is responsible for the current
threat also two direct appeals to putin
saying president putin do not
underestimate the strength of
democracies and president putin and i
think this certainly was the most
headline worthy probably of these
messages
loosened the noose around the throat of
ukraine and he pointed out that that
threat is not only to ukraine but also
to other eastern neighbors and in fact
his first foreign trip this coming week
will be to latvia one of the baltic
republics that does feel threatened but
he went on to join that theme with uh
the threats to democracy at home talking
about the fact that both the pandemic
and also the transformational process
we're seeing as germany moves away from
fossil fuels to new energy systems to a
more green economy that these are
sources of pain and division within the
society and he talked about how he wants
to be a president who listens to those
who are fearful about the future who
listens to their concerns and that he
would make his first domestic trip to
eastern germany where many people do
feel that the future is less secure
perhaps than the past
okay and i'll just go back to to to to
nina if i may who's uh there at the
bundestag forest can you tell us a
little bit more about how the day
unfolded um i understand the voting was
i mean we watched it live it was bit
tricky with the pandemic it's not in the
usual place there were celebrities and
so on what more can you tell us
well yeah i report from the bundestag on
a very regular basis and today was very
different from our usual reporting of
course one because the federal
convention is such a unique body it only
gets together once every five years and
its sole purpose is to elect the german
president now the federal convention is
made up of all the members of parliament
here and all the parties get the same
amount of votes that they can then
essentially hand to people from all
walks of life from representatives of
society who they think stand for their
own values and so we've had a very
colorful uh very um diverse mix of
people here in bundestag today there
were rappers there were football
superstars angela merkel the former
chancellor was here so very different
and usually it's a day where germany
celebrates its democracy now we all
famously um are not the kind of nation
that puts too much glamour into its
democratic processes but the federal
convention meeting is usually one such
day where we celebrate democracy with
symbols and rituals but because of
anti-covet rules that are still in place
there was a lot of focus on keeping your
distance from each other and also from
everybody had to get tested who came in
here and also when they played the
national anthem you weren't allowed to
sing but you were allowed to hum
yeah and i'll note in passing that while
it was all about frank falterstein it
seemed like everybody wanted a selfie
with angela merkel political
correspondent nina has at the bonus tag
there for us and melinda craner chief
political correspondent here in the
studio thanks so much
you